puis un groupe d'experts conclu que les
radiofréquences émises par les
téléphones cellulaires les réseaux haifa
et les compteurs intelligents entre
autres n'ont pas à proprement parler des
effets sur la santé bref santé canada
conclut qu'il n'ya aucune raison pour
changer sa réglementation normand
grondin explique
les opposants au compteur intelligent
d'hydro-québec vont être déçus la
société royale du canada me des
nombreuses organisations repencher sur
les risques potentiels des
radiofréquences arrive à la même
conclusion que tous les autres ils sont
sans danger
mandaté par santé canada les experts de
la société royale ont fait une revue
exhaustive des nouvelles études sur la
nocivité des radiofréquences émises par
les cellulaires les antennes de radio et
de télédiffusion le réseau sans fil et
les compteurs intelligents notamment
conclusion aucune étude d'un démontriez
solide entre l'exposition au niveau de
radiofréquences permis par santé canada
et des problèmes de santé comme le
cancer du cerveau l'infertilité les
troubles de mémoire ou de sommeil et
même ce qu'on appelle l'électro
hypersensibilité
selon ce spécialiste des radiofréquences
du cellulaire la société royale du
canada a réalisé un travail solide
également nécessaire c'est certainement
utile de d'informer le public
périodiquement sur l'état des chaussures
une question qui est aussi personnel et
que à la fois le cancer et les
téléphones cellulaires c'est quelque
chose qui touche tout le monde
maintenant pour sa part le physicien
richard leonelli rappelle que les
conclusions de la société royale sur les
compteurs intelligents recoupe celle de
la vaste majorité des experts
internationaux à un mètre de distance
d'un compteur intelligent
la densité de puissance aux quelques kg
est exposé environ cent mille fois plus
petite que celle à laquelle nous expose
un téléphone quand on parle ou
téléphoniques ont leur compte la tête
bon en ce qui me concerne ça règle le
problème des compteurs d'hydro-québec
indirectement le rapport de la société
royale du canada on voit quand même un
message très clair à la quarantaine de
municipalités qui réclame maintenant un
moratoire sur l'installation des
compteurs intelligents dans ce dossier
la science et les scientifiques sont
contre eux ici normand grondin canada
montréal